call me red stool the treatment didn't
give me powers but it did spread cancer
to my anus hey everybody you're probably
like wait a minute why did family guy do
a giant Deadpool scene well remember
that Ryan Reynolds has done three
episodes of FAMILY GUY one of them was
like the entire episode
hey Ryan Reynolds what are you doing at
Cleveland's house well believe it or not
they've decided to shoot my movie in
Quahog instead of Newport I'm playing
Hitler but is a young Hitler and he's
got a rocking body it's called hot ler
huh Color Me seven bucks lighter hey I'm
so excited that we're gonna be neighbors
we should totally hang out good evening
everyone welcome to whispers I'm your
hostess Ida and as always I am joined by
my trusty psychic Ryan Reynolds I knew
you'd say that
ha ha ha piano comedy what don't you do
windows ha ha ha trust me folks
he doesn't I've tried plus Family Guy is
Fox Deadpool is Fox although technically
Disney owns them both now remember
disney bought pretty much all of fox's
content not the TV stations that they
own but the content which means Family
Guy but I've gotten a lot of questions
about whether or not Ryan Reynolds is
actually gonna do the voice for the
animated Deadpool series when it
premieres later this year or if it's
gonna be someone else like Nolan North
because Nolan North has done the voice
for Deadpool at least 6 or 7 times
mostly for the video games some dingus
word writers gonna know better than me
how to show how amazing I am amazing is
more spider-man's thing but the funny
thing is is it the first time we saw the
Deadpool character on-screen in 2009 and
Wolverine Origins when Ryan Reynolds
played him was also the same year that
Nolan North did the voice of Deadpool
for the first time so both of their
versions of Deadpool debuted during the
same year although to be
to Ryan Reynolds I think that the
version of Deadpool that he's doing now
is sort of an evolution of that previous
version of Deadpool there's almost like
two different characters but this is the
voice of nolan north in the deadpool
game which is where most people remember
him being deadpool calling the actual
voice actor as nolan or so this gives
you an idea for what he would sound like
in the animated series know it hey
what's up buddy
we're making the game about me we've got
to have you do the deal now you see
here's the thing people tell me we sound
alike that sounds awesome Deadpool aside
a different take on it maybe we just
make you you know maybe it's an
alternative type of Deadpool you know
it's somebody yeah well [ __ ] you know
hopefully when we wake up you'll be gone
we just had the greatest idea for a
level in the game tits so if you guys
didn't know the Deadpool
animated series is going to be 10
episodes it'll be on FXX so it's still
relatively Fox based but it's being
produced by Donald Glover and his
production house in conjunction with Fox
and marble if you're questioning whether
or not Ryan Reynolds you know big
Hollywood actor who's busy making films
all year long actually has the time to
dedicate to doing the voice for that
just remember that Seth MacFarlane has
done the voice for several of Family
Guy's major characters for the last 16
seasons a lot of the recording for that
happened while he was on the film set
directing and writing all three of his
movies so while he was doing both of the
Ted movies in a million ways to die in
the West he was also going to a
recording studio where they were filming
those movies and doing the voices for
all the Family Guy characters so if Seth
MacFarlane can do the voice for Peter
Stewie Brian quagmire carter
pewterschmidt in any additional voices
as necessary for the episode at the same
time as he's directing a major Hollywood
motion picture then I think it's totally
reasonable for Brian Reynolds to record
lines for Deadpool animated episodes
between or while he's doing other movies
but I'd be like either way they go if
they decide to go with Nolan north just
because Ryan Reynolds isn't sure whether
or not he can make that time commitment
or make it happen I think he can I don't
think there's any problem with that but
Nolan north is also amazing his Deadpool
and he's a voice actor by trade so he's
just used to doing stuff like this but
most people identify Ryan Reynolds with
Deadpool now so I think that's the
preference if it's at all possible to
have him do the voice you may not have
heard about it but DC Comics is doing a
new Harley Quinn animated series that's
a little more adult and they're actually
trying to get Margot Robbie to do the
voice for that so there is sort of a
trend in Hollywood now where if you have
a character that's identified with a
specific person then you try to maintain
that consistency across all versions of
the characters with the exception being
like some of the Marvel animated series
on Disney there are a lot of Marvel
cartoons in most of the Marvel actors
that you're gonna see an infinity war in
a couple months do not do the voices for
those so like Robert Downey jr. does not
do the voice for animated Iron Man Chris
Pratt doesn't do the voice for animated
star-lord but I think that's just
because those actors aren't quite as
good at doing voice over as other actors
are so if you do have a live-action
actor that's really good at that like
Ryan Reynolds is actually really good at
doing animation then it makes sense that
they would go after him for that and I
know he really likes Donald Glover so
hopefully there's a relationship there
but let me know in the comments if for
some reason they're not able to get Ryan
Reynolds to do the voice for animated
Deadpool in the series who do you want
them to get I feel like Nolan North is
probably everybody's first Pig but we'll
just find out about that in a couple
months they're probably gonna try and
use the movie to piggyback on that PR to
get people excited about the animated
series so when we get closer to may
remember the movies coming out May 18th
now that's probably when they'll start
dropping more information about the
animated series but if you're just
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get everything I'm even
doing an Infinity Gauntlet giveaway on
all my Marvel videos so I'll announce
the winner the next time I post a Marvel
video but in related news if you guys
didn't know there's a new cartoon from
Olin Rogers called final space I'm gonna
do a trailer video for that later this
week that's premiering next week in it's
sort of a Rick and Morty style adult
animation space based sci-fi series so
it's actually pretty funny I'll do a
video for it in a couple days so if you
guys don't know what's going on with
that you'll totally understand so no
worries
you can't succeed your lil hero
your father was
[Music]
are we going home dad I guess the best
but I'm not gonna leave you here I
promise I'll do whatever it takes
[Music]
while you wait for everything click here
to watch Ryan Reynolds prank
Jane Malik for his birthday which is
pretty hilarious and you can click here
for brand-new infinity war thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]